this program is brought to you by Emory
University good afternoon i'm randall
Birkett I'm the curator of
african-american collections and the
manuscript archives and rare book
library here at Emory and delighted to
welcome you on behalf of the Graduate
Institute of liberal arts the department
of african-american studies and the
library who together are co-sponsoring
our symposium this afternoon on race and
sports in American culture the occasion
marks two significant developments in
african-american collections in our rail
Book and Manuscript library which the
first of which is we're opening a new
collecting area in marble related to
african-americans and sports we think it
is a critically important subject for
scholarly research and understanding to
understand the relationship between
sports and society and sports the
intersection of race and gender issues
as they intersect with sports and
society and the first collection that we
acquired and the collection that helped
spur our interest in collecting in this
area are the papers of Clyde Parton
senior much beloved figure at Emory for
many years who recently passed and his
his widow and the family decided to
donate the many of the manuscripts
correspondence I have some of the
memorabilia books from the library that
he assembled over a lifetime of interest
in the world of sports and we have a few
cases at the end of the session we
invite you to browse around he had a
wonderful collection of Hall of Fame
signed baseball's other baseball's team
balls there are materials from his
collection but also some samples from a
range of other
materials that we've gathered in the
course of building african-american
collections the second important
development that we're marking is the
appointment of pelham McDaniels as
curator for this area of collecting he's
also going to be working in the area of
civil rights and others with me pelham
is well known I'm sure he's better known
to many of you than I am to you he is
the most known factor on this campus we
it never takes less than 20 minutes to
walk across the campus because people
just seem to come out of the the doors
the the windows they come to say hello
give greetings so we're welcoming pelham
back he completed his PhD in ila in 2007
his dissertation was angles of a cent
race class sport and representation in
African American masculinity he was a
star athlete at Oregon State University
he was a professional had a professional
career with the NFL he was also a star
academic scholar at Emory where he is
now making his name in the academic
world with his research and teaching and
writing and he is he working as a
consultant with us to develop this area
he's continuing his appointment as
assistant professor of history at the
university of missouri at kansas city so
we are delighted pelham to have you a
part of the Marvel team it's and I will
say that the program this afternoon is
the first of a series of programs that
we anticipate he will be developing in
relation to the collections that we're
acquiring the public scholarship
dimension of the materials that we
acquire in Marvel is a very important
dimension of gathering we don't just
want to gather the materials and put
them up on a show
off we want you to use the materials and
we want to develop public programs that
enable you to interact with folk who
have done research in the area related
to our collections I will say he has a
collaborator in the development of this
program Dana White recently retired
professor of American Studies in the ILA
has recently been received on waivers
from Iowa to marble and he is going to
be working with us to help build
collections and develop programs we feel
very strongly that it's critical to have
a solid scholarly and academic
underpinning to the materials that we're
collecting to enable the analysis and
and and better understanding of sport
and American society he has taught
regularly courses on baseball and
American culture here but we have a
range of faculty across the university
who are interested in this area Carol
Anderson in african-american studies
Jeffrey lesser in the history department
William Gruber in English who has team
taught a course with Dana White Clyde
partner at the Medical School Clyde part
and junior has been very interested so
with this deep faculty interest and our
growing student research interests in
this area we felt it as important for us
to reflect those interests in are
collecting and we're delighted to to be
able to open this new area of collecting
for marble with that I will turn the
program over to pella McDaniels who will
moderate to introduce the panel and
moderate followed by there will be
conversation we have will have some
refreshment have an opportunity for you
to look at the exhibition so thank you
very much for coming tell them welcome
we are delighted
as always it's a pleasure to come back
to to Atlanta especially to Emory where
you know I did my work and spend a lot
of time and have made a lot of friends
and colleagues and really enjoyed coming
back home is what i like to say
sometimes sometimes but before we begin
I have to do what is always need to be
done when you're doing these types of
events you need to thank the people who
actually made it possible first and
foremost I want to thank Randall Birkett
for what do we say recruiting me
drafting me on to another project that
you know guarantees to be not just a
whirlwind but something that's going to
be exciting for everyone who's involved
I don't know if you all remember this
but back in 2006 we participated
together along with Tiffany Gleason
another graduate student on the curation
of the Carter G Woodson collection which
also produce an exhibit catalog and it
actually traveled for about a year
across the country especially became a
Kansas City which is away from Atlanta
so we can say across the country but
that was that was an exciting time for
me I was completing my dissertation and
have an opportunity to work directly
with Randall and Special Collections
also like to thank dr. white dr. Vanna
White colleague now has been keeping
people in line as I traveled between
Kansas City in Atlanta he's been the
eyes and ears and hands and feet and
working with Mashhadi and Special
Collections gathering everything to
present so for sits today so you all
would have a chance to see what's in the
collection so that's I appreciate that
thank you very much from an
administrative standpoint we can't
forget our vice provost and director of
libraries recluse and also interim
director ginger came for their support
of this endeavor and really meeting with
me one on one of different occasions to
talk about the future of what we would
like to do at Emory as it relates to
Special Collections in african-americans
in the collection Randall had alluded to
this idea that we want to expand on what
we do and part of that is producing
products that come out of our research
things that will travel
talking about digital collections but
also digital exhibitions we're talking
about curriculum all the things that you
can produce from these collections and
exhibitions that we have to start
thinking about that will not only give
us a larger presence in the academic
community but will allow for our
students to learn in different ways and
so those are these are the things that
we're going to discuss over the coming
months and years I have to make one also
announcement or at least introduce
someone to you who has also been a part
of this dick and Pam Cecil our friends
friends of not only myself but friends
of Emory and they have taken us in and
they have a significant collection that
they would like to give our University
related to sports that that will be a
very very important part of what we do
in the future so just to say thank you
thank you dig Thank You Pam last but not
least I have to say how appreciative I
am of the Emory community as a whole
Randall also said that when I walk
across campus people jump off the window
to say hey to me that's not always true
but it's been one of those situations
where bringing new colleagues to our
campus dr. Gerald Olli and Michael and
who's been here this is something they
have to experience they have to
understand that presenting here at Emory
is not just something you do when you
move on and and hopefully you'll come
back and invite it I think our students
and our faculty appreciate when we have
visiting scholars present their work to
our community because it enrich is who
we are and in our work so thank you very
much for for coming ok so as most of you
know this week the Atlanta Braves is
hosting a major league baseballs and
we'll civil rights game and it's going
to take place on Sunday against the
Philadelphia Phillies are you a
Philadelphia Phillies fan somewhat some
way as as a
as a formal introduction to a new focus
in Emory University's manuscripts
archives read books library on
african-americans in sports professor
Dana White Randall Burkett and myself
recognize that this week would be the
most appropriate time to host a
symposium to complement the activities
planned around this very important game
today's symposium is intended to examine
the intersections between race and
sports in American history and provide
an open forum for a conversation about
the challenges ahead there are three
underlying goals of this public
presentation first to provide a space
for a dialogue that addresses the impact
of individuals such as Jackie Robinson
and Hank Aaron to name but a few on
American culture through their
individual and collective participation
in sports second to interpret the impact
of sports and racing sports and civil
rights history and three to provide the
space to discuss what is next beyond the
traditional memorialization and come
amor Kimura Kim amore commemoration I
apologize commemoration Thank You
Randall of the breaking of racial
barriers in sports it's not too
difficult say the panelists this
afternoon will speak to these questions
in an attempt to help us understand the
importance of collecting the papers of
African American athletes and how
studying their past contributions and
their impact on civil and human rights
issues can shed new light on the
significance of sports in the
development of african-american social
political and economic empowerment our
first presenter is the director of the
Center for the Humanities and the
Murrell cleaned professor of modern
letters at Washington University in st.
Louis professor drilled early is the
author and editor of numerous volumes
including lore and loathing essays on
race identity and the ambivalence of
assimilation body language riders on
sport the culture of bruising essays on
prizefighting literature and modern
American
which by the way one in 1994 a national
book critics circle award for criticism
and he is currently completing a book on
Fisk University in 1997 dr. early was
elected to the american academy of arts
and sciences and has been a recipient
the recipient of several wars from the
National Endowment for the Humanities
the mellon Foundation and the General
Electric foundation one of the most
interesting things that I recently
learned about him in the process of
gathering this information was that he's
been nominated twice for Grammy Awards
now both of them before writing the
liner notes correct for albums Joe Riley
please good afternoon everyone and I
thank you all for coming out night I'd
like to thank Randall Burke it and tell
him for inviting me to come talk to you
today and so I like to make a few
remarks and mostly most of my remarks
are about two athletes said that you
know very well in any discussion about
sports they're past their present their
future and particularly their
relationship to race I think three basic
questions ought to be addressed before
proceeding to any others the first
question is what is a high performance
athlete and what is the nature of his or
her appeal to the public the second
question is whether high-performance
sports and why do they exist and the
third is how does race affect the
answers to the first two questions I
shall offer some thoughts on all three
of these questions on the front page of
the April 25th may first 2011 issue of
sports business journal is a story about
Philadelphia Eagle quarterback Michael
Vick entitled Vicks rehabilitation as
endorser acela rates we learn from the
article that Vick quote has agreed to do
a 70 to 90 minute documentary film
chronicling his his life with bombo
sports and entertainment unquote bombo
CEO
Porter promises that the film quote
won't be a sugar coating but it should
be a good film about an athlete who is
fantastically talented and really
polarizing at the same time unquote
readers also learn from the article that
if Michael Vick wins an online fan vote
he will become the cover athlete of EA
Madden's NFL 12 game quote a madden
cover would get Vic back into the aisles
at places like walmart and tour toys r
us where he was but hasn't been able to
get back into according to one senior
marketing director quoted in the article
the fact that Vic made it as far as he
did in the fan voting as a testament to
the sustained efforts of rehabilitation
of his image the fact that he was the
2010 comeback player of the year after
replacing the injured starting
quarterback Kevin Cobb has certainly
helped Victor 8ly cop who had been the
Eagles number one quarterback was unable
to get his job back when he returned
from his concussion because Vicks
performance was so extraordinary as the
old saying goes nothing succeeds like
success Vic throwing 21 touchdowns last
season and running for nine more remains
one of the most exciting players in the
NFL and is in fact a better quarterback
now than he was before his imprisonment
when he was the starting quarterback for
the Atlanta Falcons as things have
turned out Vic actually wound up losing
the madden game cover by nearly two to
one margin to Cleveland Browns running
back Peyton Hillis the fact that dick
lost the the madden game cover by such a
wide margin indicates that they are
still probably a substantial number of
sports fans that are repelled by the
crimes for which he went to prison but
the fact that he may over time
especially if he continues to perform
well for the Eagles be able to overcome
the stigma of being an ex-con who
committed acts that were not only
illegal but shamefully cruel and become
again even a somewhat marketable athlete
in the commercial world as a remarkable
story or let us say it's a remarkable
story line as the press has very much
help to shape quote the redemption of
Michael Vick unquote as his narrative
arc the story about Vic in the Sports
Business Journal fits this
to refresh your memories you may recall
then in august two thousand seven
michael vick pled guilty to felt federal
felony charges of operating an unlawful
dog fighting venture what made matters
worse for vick in the eyes of federal of
federal prosecutors and in the eyes of
the public is that he admitted to
killing himself six to eight poorly
performing pit bulls by drowning or
hanging he was also complicit in the
gruesome murder of murders of many other
dogs that could not make the top grade
as performers the idea that a
professional athlete himself a public
performer would treat poorly performing
animals so completely under his power in
such a cruel in such a cruel sport that
he would treat them so heartlessly and
ruthlessly was to make dismaying and
enraging too many people thus vick
became the demon poster child for auntie
animal cruelty organizations and for
various animal rights groups vick was
sentenced to 23 months in prison of
which he served 19 after his release
from prison dicks signed with the
philadelphia eagles in august 2009 as a
backup to donovan mcnabb it is
interesting how thick or the people
around him engineered his return to the
NFL by associating him with black men in
football who had impeccable personal
credentials namely former indianapolis
coach Coach Colts coach Tony Dungy the
first black head coach to win a Super
Bowl and Donovan McNabb who had been
seen as a victim of racism in 2003 if
you'll recall when conservative radio
commentator Rush Limbaugh made
disparaging remarks about how the press
one the mcnabb to receipt to succeed
because of his race I know how many
remember that that was a very prominent
thing back in 2003 McNabb was also seen
as a victim and the contretemps that
erupted between him and star wide
receiver Terrell Owens after the Eagles
lost Super Bowl 39 in February 2005 when
Owens said in effect that mcnabb was not
a super bowl-caliber quarterback with so
much lurid press coverage of black NFL
players being arrested for gun
possession or being connected to
domestic or nightclub violence or
visiting stripper stripper clubs of the
NFL being turned into a league of black
love to affect cover stories about this
if you'll recall in Time and Newsweek
and the like Vic Toews his new friends
well after all Vic had been in trouble
himself before the dog fighting
conviction in 2006 he was fine for
making obscene gestures to fans in the
New Orleans Superdome in 2005 a woman
sued him for giving her genital herpes
without disclosing the fact to her that
he had the disease for which he was
secretly getting treatment under the
alias of Ron Mexico he will be called
they started putting out jerseys with
Mexico on the NFL had been squash that
moreover just one month after Vic signed
with the eagles and was reinstated to
the NFL on july 4th 2009 tennessee titan
quarterback stephen McNair was shot and
killed by his mistress who then killed
herself an unwelcome scandal for the NFL
and another unfavorable story about
black NFL players Vic needed to thread a
moral needle in his return and he
managed to do this up to this point in
this way Vic has helped himself or
enabled the press and fashioning his
story as one of redemption taking subtle
advantage as well of the belief among
the liberal educated elite about the
disproportionate incarceration of black
males as an institutional political and
cultural and justice Vic would never
publicly say that he feels he was
unfairly treated because he is black or
that he did not deserve the punishment
he was given but many blacks feel that a
star white athlete convicted in this of
the same charges would not have been
nearly as vilified as Vic was the
difference is starkly represented in the
2007 poll conducted by your black world
com that showed that while only fifteen
percent of white stop race played a role
in Vic's dilemma forty-six percent of
blacks thought that race has something
to do with it in a more recent poll
eighty-two percent of blacks think Vic
should be playing football while only 42
a percent of whites think so the idea
that a white star athlete would not have
been vilified to the same extent as Vic
for the same crime is of course pure
conjecture on the
part of those blacks who feel that way
but as there is evidence that black men
are sometimes excessively punished in
their prison sentencing and that young
black men generally have been
stigmatized and even character short as
thugs it is understandable that many
black people feel as they do about the
Vic cash this underscores the fact that
no great athlete is merely or only an
athlete whose significance is based
solely on what goes on on the playing
field athletes are also complex social
political and cultural emblems of the
two our society and of our society which
in some profound waves they have come to
represent athletes are exemplars more
emotionally deep as national legends
than virtually any other type of
performer in popular culture all public
performers need loyalty in order to
sustain themselves they need their
audiences to identify with them to form
a psychological bond great athletes
elicit more intense loyalty because they
are seen as being heroic in ways that
other pop culture figures are not what
our sports they are live dramas of
highly regulated and structured
competition stage for commercial
purposes that require enormous physical
training and mental discipline where the
outcome is unknown and usually not
predictable sports are live dramas
performed under great stress and
pressure the outcome is victory or
defeat these are the singular elements
that attract large numbers of the public
to sports and is the ability of great
athletes to perform well under pressure
that makes them heroic cannon athlete
who polarizes the public be heroic this
is the question with Vic and as and as
the sport as a sports business journal
article about Vic suggests can an
athlete be commercially successful who
is polarizing it is more likely that a
black athlete would be more polarizing
to the pub excuse me that's a question
is it more likely that the black athlete
would be more polarizing to the public
than a white one some black commentators
certainly believe that as some have
pointed
certainly believe this as some have
pointed to the recent Q score which name
this is a polling data marketing polling
data that named the six most hated
athletes in America all of them are
black they're my flirt for the record if
you want to know they are is Michael
Vick Tiger Woods Terrell Owens Chad
Ochocinco Kobe Bryant and LeBron James
active athletes it is if this is true if
this polling is actually accurate this
should lead us to ask some searching
questions about why the public sees
black athletes differently and if it is
the function of the black athlete
generally in American society to be at
times of polarizing presence and outlaw
presents a trickster figure that
enhances the black athletes
entertainment value in other words does
the black athlete as a polarizing figure
actually have more entertainment value
as such and is that one of the reasons
why the black athlete is made into a
polarizing figure in other words to be
polarizing does not necessarily
foreclose the possibility of a black
athlete having considerable financial
net and athletic success think of the
careers of Muhammad Ali or doc Ellis or
Mike Tyson or rod artists all very
polarizing figures who wound up having
great financial and athletic success
this should lead to the question if this
is true about the black athlete can this
true about this polarizing business can
it be changed should it be changed or
does the sporting public largely though
by no means exclusively made up of white
prefer for matters to stay as they are
do they prefer to have some black
athletes play a role of being polarizing
agents in society polarizing agents in
sports I shall return to these questions
in a moment it should be noted that Vick
was twice voted the most hated athlete
in America in polls taken in the last
two years in forbes magazine in december
2010 in a poll of philadelphia residents
conducted by the Philadelphia Daily News
I know this enemy territory for
Philadelphia because I'm the nest the
Phillies are your main rivals in
baseball
I know I just I grew up in Philadelphia
but don't hold that against me that in a
poll in the Philadelphia Daily News it
was discovered that as the Eagles won
more games under Vic public approval of
him increased in this particular pole
seventy-six percent of Phillip
Philadelphians has a positive opinion of
him the Eagles were playoff bound with
Vic at quarterback when the poll was
taken another important question is what
does it mean when a large segment of the
public is shown to hate an athlete what
does it mean to hate a black athlete or
an athlete of color is in hate after all
a common emotion among sports fans who
love their own favorites their own teams
and hate the opposition it has not even
always been the case then when the black
athlete is hated it is mostly whites who
hate him give you an example of the
boxer joe frazier during his hate during
the heyday of Muhammad Ali Joe Frazier
was far more hated by blacks who thought
he was an Uncle Tom than by White's is
the hatred of a black athlete always
political in some form or fashion or
does race over politicized sports today
perhaps we need to understand how sports
hatred that is the hatred sports fans
feel for the opposition or for rivals
how that works in relation to feelings
of race and how and in what ways it may
be connected with racial hatred or
racial bias maybe we don't understand
things as well as we think we do does
this combination of sports hatred and
race intensify the thrill of being a
sports fan or do black sports fans hate
certain superior white players in the
same way that some white sports fan hate
certain superior black players give you
an example did many black sports fans
hate Larry Bird as in relation to his
main rival Magic Johnson did many black
force sports fans hate Gerry Cooney in
relation to his rival Larry Holmes the
many black sports fans hate Martina
Hingis in relation to her rival the
young Venus Williams let us briefly
consider another case of a polarizing
black athlete who is currently facing
prison on April 13 2011 former San
Francisco giant outfielder and homerun
King Barry Bonds was convicted in
federal court a one count of obstruction
of justice in his perjury trial focusing
on whether he lied to a grand jury about
knowingly using performance-enhancing
steroids the jury could not reach a
verdict on the three other charges
steroid allegations have dog bonds for
the last eight or nine years and
certainly have researched his reputation
and called into question his career
accomplishments at least any of the
career accomplishments of the last of
the of the five seasons from 2000
through 2004 when everybody is pretty
sure he was taking steroids okay those
are the years those are the big give
those five years of big using question
the press has never liked him very much
they came crassly egotistical and
unbearably temperamental but his
extraordinary talents were lavishly
praised until the steroid allegations
began to take traction baseball analyst
Bill James once ranked him as one of the
five best players ever to play the game
with the press will the press create a
Redemption narrative here as it has done
with vic will bonds and his handlers
enable the press to create such a
narrative one wonders of Manny Ramirez
the star outfielder who played most
famously or infamously for the Boston
Red Sox and who suddenly quit baseball
in disgrace after testing positive for
performance-enhancing drugs one wonders
if he will be able to become the
reception of a Redemption narrative
bonds biggest hurdle in a redemption
story is that he has completely
ostracized from his sport he is too old
to be an active player and no Club has
any interest in him working in any
capacity for for it he may have no
interest in being a coach or
administrator or and some baseball
people may think he lacks the
personality to teach others or to
discover talent many clubs are surely
afraid of the reaction of their fan base
if they were to make any overtures to
employ bonds in any capacity and that
probably plays a role choke mark mcgwire
has at least a chance over time of
redeeming himself simply because he is
back in the game as the hidden coach for
the st. Louis Cardinals being able to
play has helped Michael Vick extreme
enormously with the public as the
Philadelphia Daily News poll shows a
great athlete who is also polarizing may
in fact begrudgingly admired by people
who hate him while he is still playing
the other major problem with bonds is
that he has seen as a cheater his
achievements are no longer respected
because of the cloud of steroid use
although it must be said if you look at
his record between nineteen two thousand
and two thousand for the years that he
used steroids if you through those years
out he would still make the hall of fame
with the other years that he had that's
how good he was that if you could throw
those years out and still put them in
the Hall of Fame that does not have the
victims I have that problem of having
tainted himself on the field as a
performer charges of steroids have never
steroid use have never gained traction
with Vic such is the power of sports
such as the essence of the meaning of
sports that seemingly we are more
tolerant of misbehavior even criminal
behavior by an athlete off the field as
long as he performs honorably on the
field this is precisely the issue with
baseball great Pete Rose his performance
as a player has never been called into
question yet he is like bonds a pariah
but the public perception of bonds and
rose are different over the years polls
have shown the majority of the people is
are in favor of Rose being elected to
the Hall of Fame and of being able to
return to baseball when bonds was
chasing Henry Aaron's career home run
record according to an ABC poll
52-percent opposed his pursuit and only
thirty-seven percent were in favor of it
the same poll showed the majority of
blacks though in favor of bonds pursuing
the record it is interesting that at the
time when bonds broke the record Aaron
received a great deal of supportive
press he became an even greater sports
hero than he had been before but for
many African Americans the situation
seemed as if whites were making Aaron
the good negro and bonds was to use a
vulgarity the bad nigger that praising
Aaron permitted whites to cover cover to
denigrate bonds in their efforts to
uphold the moral sanctity of baseball
blacks had a right to be a bit
suspicious of the moral fervor which
with whites were suddenly defending the
sanctity of sports records i have
written i had written an op-ed piece at
the time suggesting that all records in
baseball before the integration of
baseball such as DiMaggio's 56-game
hitting streak in the light should be
marked with an asterisk to remind the
public that these are in fact white
records I was roundly condemned for this
piece but I was merely trying to play
sports records in their proper moral
light has Hollywood contribute in any
significant way to how we see black
athletes and race in sports did films
like The Rocky series or Hoosiers or any
given Sunday essentially present the
black athlete and a cliched stereotype
way sports films usually glorify the
underdog show overcoming adversity as
being heroic and show in the end that
the morally superior sigh prevails over
the other side which is usually seen as
you know bad or evil or or whatever
given this template how often are blacks
the underdog in sports movies how often
are they shown to prevail over great
adversity how often have you seen a
black movie were you seeing black at the
black athletes even training to learn
your sport I mean I asked you that
question I tell you it's not many it's
not many because you know it's not how
often are they seen as morally superior
opposed to the other side I'm not
suggesting that this never happens in
Hollywood movies there is Bernie Mac and
mr. 3000 and Denzel Washington hair
pain and remember the titans with your
sports films that tried to present
blacks a bit differently but this is not
typically the case the fact that so many
sports movies are made is a sign of how
sports transcends the playing fields how
sports represent certain values that
people generally can admire how symbolic
sports are for the public even that part
of the public that cares nothing for
sports there are many issues to be
raised about the future of racing sports
i wish i could go on talking about the
movies but my time is running out so i
can't say anything more about the movies
but you can ask me doing Q&A if you like
there are many issues to be raised about
the future of racing sports 1 the use of
Latino players and professional baseball
and the economic relationship of the
United States to baseball producing
countries in the Caribbean and Central
America you might rira Brooks new book
race ball and it which is a very good
book that deals with this subject the
increasing use of public monies in
public space to subsidize professional
sports in big cities and what this means
to black taxpayers and city dwellers the
increasing pressure on sports leagues to
adopt more free market practices and
what this means to black athletes and
blacks in general you know sports
leagues are basically monopolies that
were invented in the 19th century I mean
they're their business structure from
the 19th century and so what's going to
happen with this business structure
hitting the reality of the 21st century
and the increasing pressure of free
market practices which is what the NFL
players strike what is partly about is
to try to get the league to adopt more
free market practices but I will return
to a question I posed earlier if it is
true that the black athlete plays the
role of the polarizer can it be changed
or does the sporting public largely
though by no means exclusively made up
of whites prefer for managed to remain
as they are part of the answer to this
lies in the fact that blacks themselves
have mixed feelings about sports as an
image the fact that black step success
have been successful in many areas of
sports as performers
and even as coaches and managers has
been a source of pride but blacks also
feel that sports have stigmatized them
and made them seem even less able to do
intellectual things blacks are also
concerned about whether the increasing
riches of the star athlete serve their
communities well when Michael Jordan
refused to endorse harvey gantt for the
senate in south carolina in 1990 and
1996 many african-americans wish that
black athletes would serve as better
role mom would service that a role miles
if they were more political I wonder if
this is true but Jordans refusal to
endorse was seen as part of a larger
problem of black athletes who seemed
estranged from the black communities
that spawned them have the riches of
star black athletes made black
communities better or have they simply
made black children crazy for material
possessions for all the wrong reasons
can the black athlete and the black
rapper for that matter represent
anything other than material achievement
can blacks aspire to be something more
than then entertainers which is
something a woman once said to me when I
spoke about african-americans and sports
in the future the black public itself
must begin to articulate its own vision
about sports what it finds valuable
about sports and most importantly what
role they feel sports up to play in the
lives of their communities this means
counter-intuitively that
african-americans must as a group takes
sports far more seriously than they do
now not as a form of entertainment or as
an expression of popular culture not for
glamour and not for making heroes of
millionaires but there's a cultural
political social and economic force in
the world that is in fact changing the
world sports are a form of power and it
will be good for all when this is
finally fully understood thank you very
much
our next speaker is a former NBA
basketball player and the public
historian who collects rare books
newspapers and magazines by and about
african-americans Mike Glenn shares his
artifacts through traveling exhibits and
lectures from his collection he wrote
lessons from my library vol 1 Mike
Reich's and shares the inspirations and
accomplishments of pass African American
heroes who face obstacles of oppression
racism bigotry ignorance and hate he has
written 11 biographical treatise on
various African American athletes he has
skillfully paired contemporary
perspectives on life and success with
that of great leaders and philosophers
who left us with a strong legacy of
courage and mental toughness Mike Glenn
thank you all very much very happy and
pleased to be here with you let me first
review a little bit inch and share with
you how I counted was born into many of
these lessons and situations that I now
find myself compelled to be a
participant in okay growing up here in
Georgia in the south where my dad had
started the basketball program actual
sports program at Georgia School for the
Deaf and coached every sport they had at
a time of segregation he was a coach and
the founder of sports programs at
Georgia School for the Deaf he had
started that a few years before I was
born and remembering back i can remember
at about the age of five or six going
with my dad to some practices and never
knowing fully what to expect and what
all is coaching and all of that was all
about so i went with that in the gym at
about five years old and the girls on
his team these were high school deaf
girls and boys that he coach they
started running up to me and they were
picking me up and they were kissing me
on the job now you know when you're five
years old you just don't know how to
appreciate those kisses like you care
later on in your life I started the Yale
dad helped me these girls are attacking
me out here and they're not even said
anything they thought that was so funny
he just started to laugh and then he
explained to me though he said Mike
these girls are deaf he says that mean
they can't hear or talk to you he said
but they want to be your friend he said
if you want to be their friend you'll
need to learn some sign language now I
thought about that at five years old and
I decided okay I'll learn some sign
language now the girls on dad's team
just adopted me into their culture I
remember there had this one girl on his
team her name was Mildred and a last
name was Nelson she was the best player
on his team matter of fact milk is the
best player in the history of Georgia
School for the Deaf milcha was a
beautiful girl she had smooth dog
beautiful skin
at that time I thought she looked like a
Hershey's bar and so milk it started
teaching me things she start teaching me
my ABC's she start teaching me signs
like Daddy and Mommy and home and II and
play and a lot of different lessons on
sharing and inclusion that would stay
with me throughout my life I would go to
the gym and I would clap to Mildred and
she was knocking down jump shots and
Mildred was my first hero and I just
wanted to learn how to shoot that
basketball like Mildred and sometimes on
the road games I would sit on the bus
and try to sit beside Mildred and I
learned just so many lessons on
basketball and sharing and inclusion
from deaf kids and then dad start
teaching me other lessons then start
telling me about other great basketball
heroes as I started to really love and
appreciate and idolize other sports
figures in our history he would tell me
about three famous people whose names
all begin with J he would tell me about
Jesse Owens and he would talk about
Jackie Robinson and then he also would
talk about Joe Lewis he would talk about
sitting around and how important it was
to the whole black community to just sit
around that radio when Joe Lewis was
would fight and when he would win how
much it meant and how important it was
and I didn't have a true understanding
of how great and how significant sports
was over all other than those three guys
I knew from my conversations with my dad
and my mom how important Jackie Robinson
Joe Lewis and Jesse Owens had been to
the black community and the feelings of
liberation and his feelings of I am
somebody all of that was caught up into
essence of their performing on a sports
level I went on and went on through
school both my parents are teachers and
develop a lot of appreciation for
various figures throughout history and I
became a book collector kind of travel
the same path that my good friend
Randall Burke it had traveled and
collecting books and newspapers
and artifacts and documents of
african-american history and culture and
professor loans books and all of those
kinds of things I collected and then I
heard this conversation one time that
that kind of included expanded my
collecting and my focus it was a special
on one of the sports networks and they
were doing a comparison they were
talking about Barry Bonds and all of the
home runs and everything that he had all
of his accomplishments and they were
comparing him with Babe Ruth and so they
would did an outstanding job they
analyzed everything from the live ball
to the dead ball to the right hand
pitches to the left hand pictures to
every possible analysis that you could
really think of and then they came into
this one particular place where they
said but babe ruth played in a white
error I said went what did he say played
in a white error surely he meant he
played on a white team against only
white players but not in a white era
there's never been a white air on this
planet that there were not blacks so I
say oh man we have to do something about
this we've got to tell this story in a
more accurate in a more inclusive way we
can so that's when I started collecting
and exhibiting and writing and showing
and telling it participating and
representing through the media as I
worked in the media now as a broadcaster
and I have for about almost 20 years of
telling the stories from a different
perspective I started doing half time
specials during Black History Month and
as I was growing and learning of course
I knew about jack johnson and his is
brave and his triumphs and how he really
changed America and how he had this
great fight on july 4th 1910 and it's
the biggest sports event in the history
of our country today and is also at
Arthur Ashe agreed he's the most
significant athlete in American history
so learning about jack johnson and all
of his triumphs i started to study and
he talked about this one fighter named
tom
no so now who was Tom Molineaux why
don't I know about him and in this study
I found out that the first great athlete
in American history was a black boxer
named Tom Molineaux see how could this
possibly be that being a sports person
and being a person who studies and reads
and knows about sports figures I have
never heard about the first great
athlete in our country's history so I
started writing books and this book is
titled the integration of sports history
and I'll just read a little bit to you
from my forward before I tell a little
bit share a little bit with you about
Tom Mullen or why I think he and others
are very important in this volume I
share stories that reveal the character
of sports pioneers who have often been
neglected omitted or silenced their
history legend and legacy that laid the
foundation of great American sports must
be revered remembered and restored these
heroes must no longer be made invisible
their great accomplishments covered as
though they were shameful or minor must
be exposed and recognized as a
foundation for future generation of
athletes after all it was not their
decision to segregate the leagues in
steel racism and discriminatory policies
and unjust laws into our society they
protested against injustice and
demonstrated athletic excellence that
was second to none when professional and
collegiate sports were integrated black
athletes who participated were
recognized for some of their
accomplishments however black athletes
who preceded the integrationists were
dismissed marginalize are made
insignificant it was made to seem as if
they never existed while constant praise
an acknowledgment was given to white
athletes who played in the same error
presently black stars are reluctantly
mentioned and sometimes with resistance
during the annual celebration of Black
History Month sports history has never
been integrated that responsibility now
falls upon the shoulders or sports or
levels of this generation Sports has
always been matched
call in its ability to break down
barriers of race language culture
religion and nationality the same feat
of breaking down educational social
legal and economic walls was
accomplished with the leadership of
Frederick Douglass Harriet Tubman
Thurgood Marshall Walter White Rosa
Parks and Martin Luther King jr. now
with a willing heart and the open mind
will be led to understand and learn more
about the lives of bill Richman Tom
Molineaux saw white and other forgotten
black athletes and use this newfound
inspiration to restore some of American
heroes to their proper places so our job
of breaking down barriers and sharing
the stories of these athletes will be a
lot easier and a lot more fun so I
reflected back on the words of Carter G
woodson who said we have a wonderful
history behind us that reads like a
history of people in a heroic age we've
gone back to that beautiful history and
it's going to inspire us to greater
achievements now with this I went back
to Milano to his story of a man who was
enslaved and grew up in Virginia and he
grew up in a family of great fighters
where his dad Zachary had never been
defeated and all of his uncle's were
great called warlike figures and it was
the time when blacks were pitted against
each other for the sometimes gambling
for the sport against other blacks on
other plantations and as Tom Molineaux
was undefeated and wanted to be just
like his dad he grew in Fame and in
statue and eventually it was apparently
one big fight that his enslavers said I
would bet possibly the entire plantation
if you're able to win this fight and if
you win it you would get your freedom so
mullineaux was able to get his freedom
and and won the fight and there was laws
across the country and in the state of
Virginia that was if you were free to
manumit it you had so long where you had
to leave the state of Virginia it was
unbelievable laws of suppression and
oppression at that time so mullineaux
went to New York way stayed for about
five years and James Weldon Johnson and
his book man had
that at that time that was the
headquarters of Negro boxers so this
fighter from the South who had defeated
all challenges here went to New York and
45 years defeated all worthy challengers
and now all of a sudden some of the
sailors that were coming in and out of
the ports were telling him yes you
defeated everyone here there's nobody
that can beat you but the heavyweight
championship of the world is in London
at that time English had resurrected a
sport that had started in ancient Africa
centuries earlier but it kind of died
down and the period of the Roman empires
with all of thee as they took it too far
with all of the things in the roman
amphitheatre is etc and it had
resurrected in London England and if you
were the champ of England you were the
heavyweight champion of the world so
with extraordinary courage that any
athlete of the day would be tremendously
proud of this first great athlete in our
country's history said ok I'm going to
get on a boat and I'm going to go to
England to be heavyweight champion of
the world so he had the audacity of a
Muhammad Ali and the courage and the
confidence of any great athletes that we
have today so as mullineaux made his way
to England he left at a time when Thomas
Jefferson was still president of the
United States was in 1809 and he fought
his way up and he actually ran across a
bill Richman who was a guy that had left
America black guy had left America
during a revolutionary war and had
become a great fighter himself so he
actually trained Tom Molineaux Milano
became a great fighter and got all the
way within two fights it was determined
that only the world champ was qualified
to fight it against this great friday
Tom Molineaux so on December eighteenth
1810 which I celebrated this year with a
very special ceremony where we had the
200-year anniversary of the first great
fight by an American that was on the
world stage Tom Molineaux fought against
Tom Korea 200 years ago I thought it was
worthy of celebration and a worthy of
note as much as we love sports as
important as sports is to America that
this 200-year anniversary should be
commemorated was that to where we were
truly hahahahahahahaha so I felt this
that the commemorated so i did in the
best way I got an exhibit together and I
got some great athletes together some
nolan richardson's and Negro League
players and other people and we got
together and we celebrated the 200-year
anniversary of this great fight of this
great champion America still for some
reason refuses to really embrace and
celebrate and recognize our heritage and
our pasts something about controlling
the pain and control in history you kind
of control the present and the future so
I think it's very important that we
share the stories of people like
mullineaux who was the fight there has
been many scholarly articles and written
and studied about that fight and I won't
go into the details on it but he was
declared the loser by some ways that
really seemed very unfair particularly
according to today's standards that it
was really stolen from him outright he
should have been declared the champion
almost that's universally kind of agreed
that milano should have been declared
the champion but was not also there was
another thing that I think that it's
very important in the contemporary
analysis that we really have to include
also as we celebrate each year very
appropriately the success and the
importance of Jackie Robinson his impact
on sports the entire country and Major
League Baseball taking a day to
recognize him is very appropriate and
very special the thing that I have a
little problem with is that we totally
ignore the couple of players that
preceded Jackie Robinson particularly
Moses Fleetwood Walker who in eighteen
eighty four are really integrated the
white leagues at that time and we kind
of just had a gentlemen's agreement
which was what happened after Moses
Fleetwood Walker that blacks would not
be participated so historically we just
they used to say in the modern era but
they just quit saying that now they just
say Jackie Robinson integrated that
baseball which I only would call majorly
because major must assume that it's
minor muscle
but it's bigger and other must be
smaller so as he integrated the white
leagues they don't even acknowledge that
Moses Fleetwood Walker who was a
tremendous athlete he was a tremendous
catcher a tremendous runner they had
songs about him he was such a great
catcher he also was a person that had he
was a scholar had ridden one of the most
scholarly books written by an athlete
for 50 years or more it was called our
home colony where he espoused many of
the philosophies of Marcus Garvey this
was in 1908 that he really talked about
maybe we needed to move go to Africa at
various things that we would kind of
like a colony of America and we were not
really free here in America so he talked
about complex issues along with sports
so he was a great scholar he was a great
athlete Moses Fleetwood Walker should
never be thrown away we should never
just say Jackie Robinson was the first
player in a great baseball because he
was not so I think also that we as a
professor Lee was saying that as we
acknowledge now in the media when we
make comparisons and analysis of today's
athletes with previous athletes as he
mentioned Joe DiMaggio we have one of
the Dodgers who had a hitting streak of
30 games and of course they compared him
with the streak of joe dimaggio's in
1941 but never a mention was well but at
that time that was only white guys it
was just the white league baseball so I
think that if we're going to be accurate
we have to be accurate and I think we do
a disservice to everyone when we just
allow our heroes to stay in the back of
the bus so I think it's part of our
objective and responsibility is to
escort these great stars back to the
front of the bus and I really celebrate
also recently we had another special or
ceremony for the unveiling of a stamp of
rube Foster rube Foster also was a great
pitcher maybe one of the greatest
pitchers that ever pitched in
professional baseball he was a great
manager probably one of the greatest
managers who ever managed
in professional baseball as well and a
great organizer organized the Negro
Leagues in the 1920s so there's no
comparison to him to anyone in any other
culture he's kind of on a league of his
own so as we compare and as we recognize
these great athletes and coaches I think
we have to make that an inclusive
analysis I don't think we can just make
them a special footnote during Black
History Month and as we talk about the
Boston Red Sox of in 1918 we have to
talk about the Chicago American Giants
if we're going to be educated if we're
going to be inclusive and I think I've
found that people want to know about
them I don't think it's just the black
people want to know I find that white
athletes want to know and the white
public wants to know about these great
athletes what they did the context that
they did it in sometimes it's an unfair
comparison to not take into effect the
context that they played in the
discrimination the limitations all of
the things that they had to counteract
because that's a part of history too and
part of being a historian and a
collector is to recognize the context
that they that they played in so
sometimes you can't just look at
straight numbers and say all of the
great coaches were these coaches that
won this many games when others would
not allow the opportunity of played in
different circumstances etc so I think
we need more analytical more analysis
more scholarship on these areas and I
really salute the word deep ellum is
doing and I'm very happy and honored to
be a part of your discussion today so
thank you very much
okay our next panelist our final
panelist is the provost and executive
vice president for academic affairs at
Emory University and is the ASA Greg
scandler professor of history and
african-american studies dr. Earl Lewis
holds degrees in history and psychology
is the author and co-editor of several
books seven books actually among them in
their own interests race class and power
in 20th century norfolk and the
award-winning to make our world a new
history of african-americans between
1997 and 2000 he co-edited the 11 vol
the young Oxford history of
african-americans dr. Lewis co-authored
the widely claimed love on trial and
American scandal in black and white
published in 2001 by Norton his most
recent books are the African American
urban experience perspectives from the
colonial period to the present Co edited
and published with palgrave and
co-written book entitled defending
diversity affirmative action at the
University of Michigan published by the
university of michigan press let me add
that the Provost has been a great
supporter of this effort to develop
marbles new focus on african-americans
in sports and I think when we first met
with him he was really excited about the
possibility of you know bringing this
history to like here at Emory here in
Atlanta Provos Lewis
thank you and there's a pleasure in
according to Randall and using a
baseball metaphor I guess I'm hitting
cleanup for me I here and so part of
that means that I'm actually in between
you and conversation and discussion so
let me make two or three general
comments and really speaks specifically
both to the themes that Michael general
highlighted in their tops and then the
larger effort the pelham noted I mean
one of the things I think is very very
important for us all to consider is the
fact that sometimes a history is there
in plain sight but not visible and so
where my points sort of highlight the
ways in which there are stories right
before us and it only takes us to pause
long enough to actually understand their
place in significance it becomes a job
than of all of us to own that
responsibility in a way institutions
like Emery then have a special role
because we can do something and some
things that others can which is to make
sure that we archived and preserved
forever those documents and those ways
of knowing that others than they can
come back and after trying to piece
together story so the first piece here
is then about the role of actually
identifying a what deserves to be
preserved not everything that I have
seen in people's closets or basements
are and churches really should be
preserved forever and so there's a
there's some order to all of this where
we actually tried to wrestle with how
important is it and why did we want to
actually claim part of the 10th floor or
the 11th floor wherever I am marble here
in the woods of library and to hold on
to this forever mean that becomes a role
of not only then uncovering those things
that are in plain sight but also asking
the question anything Jarrell was
wrestling with the notion of race in
American life the intersection between
african-americans and sport
is really parallels the larger story
about America's deep engagement with
race me and it is that deep engagement
and I use those words carefully and that
requires us then to try to figure out
how do we make sure that this generation
and subsequent generations and then have
the tools or try to analyze the bits and
pieces that we've begun to sort of put
on the table here me how do we
understand what the the story of
inclusion because in the communities I
grew up in Virginia in the 1950s in the
1960s there was never any assumption and
that there were some people who knew how
to compete and compete well on the
baseball fields on the basketball courts
and in on the football field but they
also could do it on the tennis courts
and in swimming pools and on the golf
courses mean so there were sports that
were sort of part of the logical
modification of America that gets a lot
of attention and it's talked about
because that fees in my view the
relationship between sports and capital
and that we talk about certain things
because they sell they end up on jerseys
they end up on other products that we
can distribute I still remember the day
in 1991 and I was in Dubrovnik looking
out at this little plaza of these kids
playing basketball all wearing LA Lakers
t-shirts and I kept thinking I'm looking
for bloody d-backs name on the back of
one of them and it wasn't bloody they
were selling and Dubrovnik just before
you could slavia came apart and while in
fact while i was there you could slobby
a voter to become something other than
yugoslavia we knew in 1991 and I
remember sitting there looking at this
courtyard in these kids and I'm going
okay what is this about and then I went
to a hotel in Belgrade later on where
they were selling other parts of the
commodity industry in this case other
images of America whose early days of
rap in the early days of MTV and the
most fascinating conversation of a
European interlocutor trying to explain
malt liquor to Eastern Europe and the
ways in which Venice
urban intensely sort of identified and
commodified black culture and black
cultural experience and then was
transported across the Atlantic and I
realized there was a juxtaposition a
basketball being sold and once by and
these other images being sold any other
and you realize that deep engagement
with race it's not a singular story but
it's a multiple and integrate a story
about the ways in which we have
projected our broader image onto the
world and so then the story then of
making sure that we deal with men think
was Gerald's point about the power
dynamics that ultimately that we were
talking about in my view the story is
forcing race in American history is also
story about power there were nothing Joe
remember the names and number cities but
I can remember that when Jack Johnson
won that fight there were race riots all
over the United States I me and you're
trying to figure out okay why did people
go to the streets and riot over Jack
Johnson's defeat I mean Tommy Burns had
the temerity to actually believe that he
could beat Jack Johnson because of the
larger narrative about racing power he
believed of while he was smaller in
stature and older in age that he had the
power to beat Jack Johnson and he lost
and a whole equation upon which the
edifice of segregation Resta was called
into question and you realize that the
symbolic gesture of a ring and rope who
is sort of symbolizing then the
boundaries of a world and that you in
there squaring off with investor the
squarespace playing by quote unquote
establish rules and you win this is the
story not then just about these two men
who were bouncing it really is the
American story about a sort of deep
engagement with rakes and so we come
back then to a place like marble and our
role here is our ability then to think
about all of those stories down to
so the early pardon from 1800 down to
the most recent stories about Michael
Vick or anyone else we want to put on
the table to engage and their three
other things I think calm to the fourth
one here is is that we also need to make
sure that we're collecting materials
that allow us to deal with
african-americans as complex and human
beings I mean what I don't want is a
single a dimensional story and hopefully
the documents that we actually are able
to preserve reflect that complexity as a
native Virginian and I mean in my
community where I grew up in Tidewater
which isn't some of Newport News or sort
of part of that larger world we always
were saying you know friends of mine and
go me Michael knew better me in a
certain kind of way and even more
because his friends and you sort of
figure out who your friends are you and
you realize there are certain things you
shouldn't be doing but that actually
simplifies the story because what it
does is deal with the complexities of a
moment and all the other pieces they
actually explain how you end up in this
situation in the first place and why
isn't there some of the button in the
back of your head going off or alarm
going off saying you know I make more
money from commercials and from the
advertising than I ever will do plans
throwing a football for the Atlanta
Falcons it is that part that I'm going
to forgive up those are the pieces that
reflect the complexities but I have
always argued African American people's
have always been complex and a linear
story only begins to tell part of the
story and that's sort of part of a
challenge for us is to make sure that we
are collecting in such a way that we can
deal with those deep dimensions and the
second part of this is also we should
also invite and collect and assume that
we will always be surprised and this is
the p's than those Randall knows them
rental like a joke because Randall has
been known to call dump that what he
called the dumpster divers to I actually
sort of figure out what people are
thrown away and why they are throwing
them away
and realize that in some of those are
the treasures where we are actually
surprised by what others have decided
aren't important that we actually have
concluded along the way actually I'll
have great importance because they are
linked to and then a series of other
kinds of possibilities and a third part
is then in the last part is that as we
collect in the 20th century to remember
we're in the 21st century and that a lot
of what we collect in the 20th century
were the papers and a memoirs and the
other documents but in a 21st century we
have multiple multiple media and the
ways in which we think about okay who's
tweet and then ends up getting tonight I
sort of ways in which people respond
because what we know is that folks not
only respond maybe the polls go up with
athletes in terms of when they're
winning and when they're losing and all
but we also know people follow their
tweaks and then bury these ways in which
we need to begin to make sure that as we
collect we collect for 21st century
environment and not just for 20th
century one and that we are sort of
setting up the archives in such a way to
accommodate things they may have for me
if you think of technology to having a
life cycle every 18 months and so by the
time we get it how many generations
later and so we have to actually ask the
question if we collect it can we
actually retrieve it and how do we
retrieve it but more than that how we
retrieve it preserve it and then make it
possible for others to use I mean those
are the kinds of questions I think we
need to help because it's then going
back to the young folks who will be
reading the books and other documents
produced by Micah and Gerald and Pelham
and if I ever get back to it again of
being able to write things now we're
right but it's also the fact that now we
can actually stream the video any audio
along with what they're going to read
and you get people to actually engage in
a different kind of way of learning and
where the reader becomes the author at
the same time because they're engaging
in what's known and so I welcome I'm
both his opportunity for emory
university and signal the responsibility
that goes with it each time and it's the
folks in the library now every time they
tell me they're gonna bring another
collection in I take a deep breath
because I realize someone has to pay for
it too and that has but in and Randall
has been real good if he's got me to say
yes more often than not and so he's very
effective here but it makes me also
making sure that we asking the questions
about the future and so I share both in
your sense of deep obligation and the
complexities of the narrative narratives
plural that have been created and then
the challenges for us as we go forward
to make sure that we are the proper
stores that we seek to be when we say
that we're going to archive these
important materials so thank
okay so now as a time for QA we have a
microphone in the back if you raise your
hand mashadi know she has it right back
there if you raise your hand Mashhadi
will come through and allow you to ask
your question first of all thank you all
for a very interesting and
thought-provoking on presentation I want
to go back to a point that dr. early
made on the beginning of his
presentation about commodification of
athletics and also the commodification
specifically of black athletes and I
wanted to think about that within a kind
of intra racial construct and see if you
all might comment about that both in
terms of just your general thoughts as
well as within the context of collecting
I'm thinking kind of in in to kind of
historical eras if you will one I'm
thinking about kind of the early
creation kind of Commerce around the
personas of black athletes as was
affected by those athletes athletes
themselves I was thinking just recently
of a photograph for example that I have
of an advertisement for Joe Lewis punch
and and the ways in which that was those
advertisements appear for example in the
afro-american newspaper and such so as
wonder if you could talk a little bit
about that and then in a more modern
context or more contemporary context
thinking about the beginning I'm
imagining this is in my area but i'm
thinking of late mid to late 90s the
creation of this kind of semi
professional leagues of for example
basketball in which you know rappers and
drug dealers and the others of wealth
and black communities have began to
purchase for all intents and purposes
their own leagues and the
commodification of black athleticism
within that context and
what that means within community--and
whether there might be any possibilities
for collecting around that kind of
athleticism so three panelists who will
go first leadoff batter okay all right
very interesting perspectives on that
and there are a lot of come to the last
point about a lot of new leagues and
some that and wands and their variety of
different entertainment as well as
competitive leagues and you're right
there a lot of people getting involved
getting interested betting on doing a
variety of things from from all ages and
this sports has always been such a big
part of our communities and our passions
and and so I think in some ways it's
kind of filling a void that when we had
these leaks to leave which was a
dramatic impact on our economies and our
coaches and you had the Negro Leagues
and like basketball teams as well and so
I think a lot of this localization and
keep it going and keep it a community
like the Rutgers tournament up in New
York where it got the music and it's a
it's kind of a cultural thing as well so
so I and I think it can be collected and
you know as we keep it spending I think
you can collect there's a very good
collectible book also love the game
where they talk a lot about the athletes
that are not in the NBA the street
legends the guys who have kind of made
their fame or made the at least their
notoriety through playing on the streets
and in those kind of environment so yeah
I think there's a books to be written
things to be collected even though it's
not so much documentation and but but
now with the new ways of filming and and
all of that so yeah I think their new
horizons there to answer that party
question thank you the other the other
part of your question about for instance
to Joe Louis punch in every
a black athletes but at the time you
know Joe Lewis didn't have anything to
do with them with the manufacturing of
it he just kind of sold his name lots of
athletes did that black and white it was
very common for athletes as today as 58
years ago to try to find if you became a
star athlete to try to find ways to cash
in on your name to make money and for
instance back during the days of Jack
Johnson one of the things that boxers
did and even other know that black
athletes were to go onstage and perform
on stage because it's a heck of a lot
easier to have a little acura stage to
the exit go out box and so lots of lots
of people did that it wasn't just jack
johnson jack dempsey get white athletes
did it as well and john l Sullivan did
it and they would have stage shows and
things like that to try to make more
money because even as far back because
over a hundred years ago a star athlete
understood him himself well mostly was
him then as as as opposed to women as a
kind of commodity a understood their
name meant something that they
understood that they if they appear
somewhere they could draw a lot of
people and so they want to take
advantage of that it's of course gotten
black athletes it so far as really
getting into the endorsement game it
took a while because most of the time
they were limited to just enjoy setting
products that would be for black
audience so when Willie Mays where
people like that at first with allowed
the syrup for instance that was a
product that was mostly sold to
african-americans and so Willie Mays
would be on the owner on the poster Ford
or something like that or he would
appear in Ebony magazine for you know
Chesterfield cigarettes or something
because there was a time when a fleet in
fact endorse tobacco products to do that
doubt but they used to do that and you
know he would be in Ebony magazine it
took it took a while you can read for
instance um you know like Bob Gibson's
autobiography that he the first one he
did back in the late 60s or something
like that we complained that he was
unable to get the
of endorsement despite the fact that he
had you know been such a stellar player
and it'd been dominant in the World
Series and so forth that you couldn't
get the same kind of endorsements that
some of the white players call your
scrim ski or some of the other white
players were able to get and it took
time for that to break i would say
probably you started seeing some real
movement along those lines probably
starting in the 80s with black athletes
doing being able to do more endorsing
probably the biggest single figure i
think who really dramatically changed i
will be michael jordan michael jordan
was like Michael Jordan is a whole is
that just a book he would be a whole
series of books its effects of impact
one commercial impact on sports go I
mean he's he's a figure unto himself and
I would say he's really the key figure
who really was able to exploit himself
as a commodity and be this huge
crossover figure in a way that no other
black athlete before him was was that
kind of a crossover figure in the market
the only thing I would Eklund is that
one of the opportunities particularly in
imperia from the 1930s and to the 1960s
is actually to peer behind the the
screen of segregation and realized that
in that era was actually a larger story
a bubble up like entrepreneurial drill
and the ways in which businesses that
should get created including in world
sport and that those businesses are not
only in sports however because there's
also then a hotel business it actually
gets connected as people move from city
to city and it becomes a network and
there are eating establishments that
also become part of that Network and
then entertaining and establishments
become part of that Network and so this
period we study one piece of it you
actually have a larger story about the
rise of and the continuation of an a
competition for sort of business aspects
as well in the african-american
community where you can start that
through a story about looking at
who owned which teams and how but also
then well how about sort of multiplying
into other areas and I said 1932 the
1960s because actually things do change
after with desegregation and there's
it's interesting way about what happens
to a racial business market in the
United States particularly in the south
after desegregation I would add to that
to the week we forgot about black
jockeys in the 19th century they
themselves may not have been able to
endorse have endorsements but prior to
the Civil War their owners would have
portraits painted of them and the horses
so an Edward Troy who was painting to me
1832 the 1870s is producing these
wonderful images of the horses with
black groomers trainers and jockeys and
so this the commodification of the most
successful jockeys and groomers along
with the horses so that's another way in
which is sell black that lettuce ISM is
something that's significant next
question thank you my question is around
kind of the nature of modern media and
modern sports coverage as it as opposed
to maybe just even 20 years ago growing
up I mean even in the 80s you really
didn't see out of market players that
often unless they were playing your team
now I grew up in New York side and
multiple teams where you would see
multiple t well opponents however you
know prior to that you know you really
only knew your team and your players and
occasionally that rival but today's you
know consumption of sports we seem to
know about every team every player where
in Atlanta we know about San Francisco
Giants we know about you know LA
Clippers we know about you know it
doesn't really matter where they are we
still know about them and I wonder if
you could speak to kind of in comparison
historically to what degree did either
Negro Leagues or in major leagues or in
other sports did people know about the
lives of athletes outside of their their
particular team so if you were in
Birmingham did you know about Ken City
greys or something like that oh ma no
excuse me did you know about that
what except thank you well we did a lot
I think a lot has been lost from past
errors but they knew in their error
author ass who wrote a great book on
three-part book about black athletes he
said that the black athletes have been
the most accomplished figures in the
african-american subculture they were
vastly better known in their times than
people such as booker t washington w eb
Dubois all marcus garvey they inspired a
dollar tree bordering on deification and
thousands more wanted to follow he
compared joe gans who was a lightweight
champ during the nineteen twelve that
nineteen early 1900s said he was
possibly more popular than booker t
washington so i think we did know who
those stars were at that time but
historically they kind of get swept
under the rug and we kind of forget
about them but i think they were huge
stars in their time period I would even
there are two things I want to say so
Frederick Douglass actually endorses
Peter Jackson during the late 19th
century as he's doing wonderful things
for the race yes because he's a champion
boxer here's someone who was the
Australian an English champion who was
not allowed to fight for the american
championship because sullivan was not
going to fight a black man and in the
20th century you have the Nira league
players that are barnstorming around the
Midwest so they're bringing the news to
each town they visit on top of that you
have the Pullman porters that are
getting off at different stops maybe
they've given the newspaper from Kansas
City in some place in Omaha or
Birmingham so the news is traveling on
these railroad lines and also with these
buses with these players traveling
throughout the Midwest so there they
know they know each other and and they
you know and it's mr. O'Neill buckle
know you always talked about you know
people say you know you're bringing the
news and I think Gerald early can speak
to this with the whole baseball
phenomenom Ken Burns's that was one of
the appealing things that he brought to
that whole series was that kind of
easygoing familiar sense of you know you
could know this guy and it was that kind
of conversational style that really
appealed to people to want to know more
about this black baseball league
yes but Gerald another reason Bob Gibson
didn't get endorsements is he scared
white people beginning with white
batters but you know there's a terrible
racial injustice that I hope will be
addressed in the coming years and that's
a spectacle of white college coaches
making millions of dollars off the sweat
and labor of predominantly black
athletes who get suspended if they sell
their jersey for a thousand dollars most
of these kids are poor the few who get
pro contracts i think it's touching the
first thing they do when they become
instant millionaires they pay that they
buy their mother a house but most of
them don't get that far but what an
incredible disconnect between this disc
caste system of fabulously well
compensated coaches who are supposedly
geniuses thanks to the labor of their
athletes who get nothing and I think
it's an injustice that has to be
addressed and one of the greatest
villains in the piece as always I think
it's the n-c-double-a I couldn't agree
with you more i think you're right on
point it's always been a challenge of
how do you organize around that to
combat that power and you're talking
about young collegiate kids who don't
really have anybody to really speak for
him so i would agree because her bite
also in the audience who played with the
hawks before i did and also doing a
great documentary on black athletes in
atlanta area i might mention he's been
really lobbying hard to get funding and
support of that and i wanted knowledge
his great work and hope that any way we
can happen we should continue but also
speaks on that behalf of the athletes
who have nobody to turn to when the same
twenty dollars or whatever we got better
when we played herb is about all the
athletes get now despite the fact that
it's a billion-dollar industry now the
pot is so much larger but the athletes
get just very little of it don't know
herb has anything he wants to add to
that everyone anything to that her blank
huge concerns but there's huge concerns
of course about the amateurism for
college athletics if you start paying
the athletes and you know do you pay an
athlete based on what he brings to the
school if it's a football player and
he's you know helping to bring in
millions of dollars or it could be a
young woman who's playing lacrosse what
do you pay her so there's a lot of
thorny issues when you start getting
into paying people but yes I agree that
you know something I think needs to be
done to set up maybe something for these
kids when they get out of school so
instead of maybe receiving a lot of
funding or something they can receive
something after they get out of school
that can help continue their education
beyond two or three or four years or
whatever they do in school and and other
things to help them after they get out
of school beyond what they did you know
because what they did for the school
goes on for a long time after they leave
you know if you've got a national
championship banner hanging there up on
the you know people recognize you bring
so much to the school that goes on for
years and then you're shuffled off and
gone so yeah I think that does need to
be addressed and I appreciate the kind
words about the documentary can you say
more about that her you have a few
minutes now I think we can we can fit
you in okay Mike did mention i work at
georgia public broadcasting i've been
there for all going on about 20 years I
my group 10 minutes from here over in
Decatur Georgia just across Scott
Boulevard and I'm just going to give you
two quick two-minute my history and
that'll tell you a little bit about the
documentary I'm working on the nation
swimming pool some of you may know about
it's right there on Scott Boulevard
indicator it used to be a very private
club back in the segregated 60s it was
all white people but there was a young
guy that worked there in the locker room
a young black guy and George and I got
to be friends with him well he would see
a shooting basketballs out there in the
in the side the locker room there and he
said hey man you really want to learn
how to play basketball you need to come
over and play some a texture gym and I
knew that editor was the black
Recreation Center indicator of course
back then in the early 60s there was
white recreation center in a black
recreation center so one night my friend
bob marley and myself i think we were in
the ninth grade we decided to go to eps
turn and play basketball so we did and
that was quite a story in itself there
was kind of reverse integration here's
two white guys hipster recreation center
but the story is over the years i get to
know some guys some black eyes and they
became good friends of mine and through
them i became a very good basketball
player I was the only white guy the
other guy left town so I was playing at
debs recreation center and I would play
with these guys all summer and I would
go back and play in the white high
school league and it was like going to
the B team so bye-bye seeing you in high
school I was recognized by the Atlanta
journal-constitution is the number one
player in the state well I always felt a
little strange about that because I knew
other guys i played against all summer
that was good as me but those guys
didn't get recognized so I went on play
count and college at georgian with the
atlanta hawks and always wanted to do
something to recognize those guys had
helped me out and i started writing just
a story i thought it might be a book or
something over the years and then a few
years ago the AJC wrote some articles a
couple of guys wrote some articles about
the GI a which was the georgia
Interscholastic association which was
actually the african american high
school league in georgia pride
integration of course you had the
Georgia High School Association which
was all the white schools competed
against each other and then you had the
Georgia Interscholastic Association
which was the group of all the black
schools of course there was no play
between the schools so anyhow once I saw
those articles and I started talking
about the great athletes that played in
that league I said well you know I want
to recognize you guys have helped me but
when I recognize all those folks so I
started working on this documentary and
it's been a long haul for four or five
six years now trying to raise the money
and but it's it's the story
african american sports legacy and
georgia prior to integration and you had
people like Walt Frazier John building
modem Rayfield Wright Romeo tires Edith
McGuire Olympic athletes that the coach
is unbelievable amount of coaches and
teams that did great things that people
don't know anything about it's
unbelievable then one of the coaches at
the time said it was like we were ghosts
and so I kind of paraphrase that and the
title the documentary is as if we were
ghosts and we're working on it now and I
want to talk to Emory University a
little more about it because I know we
have some things that you may won't look
at we found some interesting documents
and you know maybe we can work with some
of your students to help us doing
research on the project but we're going
on with this and if you want to see a
short video trailer about a four minute
video trailer you can go to gpb.org
that's RF station georgia public
broadcasting gpb.org / ghosts and
there's a full minute video trailer live
narrated by and a young who works in our
building some and when I went up to him
told him about the project he said heard
I was a track athlete in high school and
the same thing happened to me so
anything I can do to help you so thanks
for the time thanks for letting me get
up and talk about it and we'd love to
have some folks give us a call about
that
we have time for maybe two more
questions torment them over here thank
you I guess one reason I have a lot of
passion about sports particularly
dealing with african-americans or just
sports in general that so reflects
what's going on in the history of the
United States I think Sports is a
reflection of racial tensions and
everything is really dramatic like a big
soap opera but one thing i will always
just stop these images are struck in my
mind I remember that because you know
for a while if you're black you were not
going to be a quarterback and I know you
ate like Randall Cunningham and yet
warren moon but there were more like
aberrations it wasn't like
african-americans work steps just
quarterbacks and then I remember for
Pittsburgh Steelers Kordell Stewart came
in but it was / yeah okay no sorry maybe
a zoo more time sorry but um it was like
you know / and to me immediately what I
thought of is how for a long time for
example in baseball for African
Americans they wanted to be a manager
you'd be like player / manager and I'm
looking at this at TV and I felt like
I'm not only one that's getting this
like it's still like that repetition of
that same those same I don't you see it
like processes going on in the same
thing with I remember Tony Dungy and you
know it's bad when even white
commentators are sitting on television
I'll never forget it was accommodating
he was saying Tony Dungy was still with
the Minnesota Vikings and everyone said
he's great and wonderful and it was
completely razed and says this man had
never been given the opportunity to be a
head coach and so now you know we have
lost a lot coaches but then the fact is
lots of them have always come under tony
dungy it's not like the league is so
there's still the way they're getting
into the league is by this one head
coach and so my point is what I would
ask you to comment on is I know we
forget a lot of our past past like way
back history but you still sort of see
these same cycles and same events still
occurring I think today and then it's
like five years later we act like it
didn't happen and I sort of feel like
it's sort of like you know you could
just be
ashing ants the things that I feel so
obviously racist but we sort of act like
okay life's great we have you know you
know Tomalin for the Pittsburgh Steelers
no problems and like did do you not
remember I grew up knowing as a for fact
if you were black you are not going to
be a quarterback and we're acting like
you know it could have been 200 years
ago okay I'll come down okay we love
that patch there's a football or bell
well I you know my comments as relates
to black quarterbacks I think that of
course it's been one of those difficult
positions to always figure out because
you're not smart enough is what they're
saying because the quarterback is the
most important position on the football
field but we know that that's not true
we know up a doug williams who won a
Super Bowl we know of a joke Gilliam
right whose brother Frank Gilliam
actually was part of the Steubenville
three they came out of Ohio and the it's
what 1960s or late 50s that were part of
the first three black athletes recruited
by major college football team in
University of Iowa so the the the
ability is there but going back to what
Provost Lewis talked about with the
racial kind of realities of stereotypes
persist it's hard to break through
because silly expectation is that these
black men who are athletic and it's a
god-given talent because we don't see
them practice as dr. early alluded to
they don't think because what's natural
is the athletic ability and so in you're
correct in saying that you know we kind
of forget about that because everything
is good right now where you have a
Michael Vick who is very athletic we
also have a down on mcnabb who's very
cerebral and so these are counters that
are in the public eye that really don't
remind you of the past because you have
these foils in a way I guess that are
constantly present but but still I think
your observation you're not crazy
because people will forget about the
past because this is what we're dealing
with and we have to when we have an
opportunity reiterate the past as it
presents itself because it does recycle
itself back to the President and one
thing to out life well gentlemen say a
few words quick words if we would I
think spike lee's done a good job at
starting a sports journalism
program over at Morehouse so that you
have voices from black reporters and
others to to say and to here's a smart
player and to kind of tell a different
side of the story and so we have the
head of that program's here today would
you want to just say a couple of just
words ron thomas street my name is ron
thomas got me shot and I've known Mike
for four years and years i use to cover
college basketball when he's played for
Southern Illinois and I've invited Mike
and he's done a couple programs at
Morehouse yeah but we called the
journalism and sports program so it's a
general journalism program but one of
the primary missions is to develop more
students into black sports reporters
because of all the newspaper sports
reporters in the country only six
percent are black and a couple of my
students are here so I'm really glad to
see them you know as perfect timing that
you just it was very nice for you to
introduce me but I want to make another
comment about your comment which is you
know there's a visual way of looking at
this whole question of lack of black
quarterbacks and lack of blacks that the
long time it took for blacks to get
these cerebral positions in football if
you look at look at the football field
the whole lineup offense vs. defense
look at it as if it was a concentric a
series of concentric circles and if you
think of where did blacks first get a
chance to play it was on the outer edges
of that circle so it would be your
running backs your wide receivers and
your D for your cornerbacks and so
that's the very outside and then if you
just think at the very center of this
some of the line scrimmage or the ball
this hike think of that as the brain of
the football of the football field so
then the next level was then you started
to get some full backs and you started
to get some may be offensive tackles and
you started to get some defensive
linemen you know and the outside outside
linebacker but the last group put two
last-place positions for there to be
blacks we're on our quarterbacks but
even probably at some point there
probably were fewer offensive centers
and then another one was middle
linebacker
remember Willie Lanier is one of the
first middle linebackers so those are
the core thinking positions in football
middle linebackers Center and
quarterback and those are all the
positions that were last for blacks to
get integrated into so to me it's just
fascinating that that it just speaks to
the fact that our intellectual ability
in sports still is diminished and even
if it's not diminished now that took a
way too long for it to be recognized we
have one more question on this side of
the room if you accept the notion that
drugs are a bad thing in the locker room
for pro sports elicit and forefront
performance hansung drugs and say that
because there may be some that say who
cares if Barry Bonds uses steroids I was
taken aback a little bit about the
amount of effort to from the judicial
system the kind of involving Barry Bonds
and even at the Congressional level
panels so I'm curious what do you guys
think about the role of Congress in
getting involved in regulating drugs in
sports don't they have better things to
do yeah I do think Congress does have
better things to do and I was at least
we hope yes yes at least we hope they
they they certainly I believe do have
better things to do and I was a bit
surprised by their intervention into
this area I believe that it's it's
debated among some people about how much
of an effect performance-enhancing drugs
actually have that's that's been kind of
debated and so there's some people who
will tell you that the effect is not as
big as as as some people would suggest
so you know that's a you know that's
that that's one issue
the other issue what you think is
probably more germane has always been if
these athletes do this would it affect
young athletes kids and things like that
and they're taking these drugs and that
would be certainly a great concern about
having young kids and so forth taking
the drugs but I don't see where any kind
of federal intervention in this really
makes a difference I think the most
effective way that would probably be
policed if they're going to get these
drugs out of out of sport would be for
the sports themselves to to police what
they're doing and I believe that that
was very you know that's that's that's
quite possible and I think it should and
it can be done beyond that it's really
nothing more I have to say about it i
think it's i think it's no longer such a
big issue in baseball it's interesting
that when Congress focused on it they
mostly focused on the big publicity was
with baseball players it was very was
very interesting that they did there was
not very much focused on athletes many
other sport it was just baseball
although we know in track and field with
Marion Jones and we we know about you
know in yeah we know about in another's
board so it was interesting that it only
got it was only a focus in baseball
which may have something to say about
the status a baseball in American life
or you know whatever but it's
interesting that it was just focused on
baseball but beyond that I do think that
there are other issues of concern if
we're interested in the athletes abuse
of his or her body there are other
issues of concern other than just
performance-enhancing drugs because
there are other ways the athletes abuse
their bodies that if if the public if
this is a if this if this is a
compelling interest of the government to
safeguard athletes there are other areas
of interest other than just
performance-enhancing drugs I do not see
that it's a it's a compelling
of the government to protect to protect
athletes I'd see that there would be
enough other people around them who
would exercise who should be exercising
that protection I don't see where the
government has a compelling interest in
it I would even add but in some ways to
24 hour news cycle creates its own
demand for maintaining a story and that
if you know that there are enough
networks that actually need to have a
story that's going to bring viewers back
and there are some that have a sort of
stinky quality to them and so the same
people who read the polls the Gerald
started referring to earlier I would
dare say if someone would spend a little
time I my guess is they're quite a few
congressional offices and where they too
were reading the pulse yeah and to
actually have your congressperson on
certain issues out front would gain you
advantages with your constituents and so
that may sound cynical but it's politics
and so you realize that the day your
left that you're running again and you
want to make sure that you stay in the
news and that you are sort of at certain
parts of the new cycle that your name is
out front and so if you go back and plot
it and figure out when these occurred
what time of the new cycle what part of
the year when be interesting to see if
there's any direct correlation between
the attempt to actually keep some
stories alive and then you layer on that
the more complicated story both about
baseball and about race and and then you
end up with a story where no matter how
many times you cut the legs up it comes
back in a new way and I'm not sure that
it mean that story had helped to produce
any additional jobs in the US has helped
to address anything about health care or
any of the other things that are
important to the body politic writ large
and so in the scheme of things
historians will judge this a minus story
but a minus story that attaches itself
to an old narrative
we have two minutes yes I appreciate
that the media has not been particularly
effective on there but I think
particularly since ron has sports
journalism students here we wouldn't be
here had it not been for the Black Press
and the pressure that they put on Branch
Rickey yeah Ches Washington for the
Pittsburgh courier is most importantly
Sam lacy for the Baltimore afro-american
and a whole raft of others and I think
it's a just worth a moment of paying
tribute to the work that they did for
four years because they kept the
pressure on on the owners and
particularly on Branch Rickey who was
predisposed I think to do it anyway but
they emboldened Tim I felt certain I'm
glad you you mentioned that that's the
Black Press played a very important role
in that the Black Press is also back to
an earlier comments question someone had
they were very important in spreading
the news about these these athletes and
actually making a kind of national black
community before you had you know
24-hour sports on precisely 150
different channels so the black crest
really doesn't get the kind of
recognition it deserves for what it has
done to serve the black community kyon
Grissom student of ron thomas Morehouse
journalism I remember mr. early talking
about the six most hated players and
just talked about arm listening to to
that list all I could think about was
like just a negative off off off court
and all field things that they have done
and it makes me think about my
generation coming out of the technology
age and we always will most young
students always look at tweets and we
always look for the negative aspects and
think about I remember Oh Cho cinco and
Terrell Owens as soon as the seasons
coming out and they were like oh man
what are they going to do together
they're going to be a crime to a dual
team and I'm just one just always
hearing about what they do off court
all field and stuff like that I just
want to know do y'all think it's ever
going to just go back to just on encore
decorum and when people are just going
to start caring about stats and start
caring about because people could tell
me all the people from Virginia can
always tell me what Michael Michael Vick
does off all feel but can't tell me that
he did 21 such passing touchdowns and
non rushing touchdowns that on recent
season in some ways part of it is there
if you think of ultra stinko and there's
a range of players let me say that and
it's hard to collapse them into any one
group in the age of Hank if not even bad
fashion immediate sort of pointing out
in the age when you really have a
product you need to have content for a
long period of time and so I mean one
may ask the question what's the crazy
what reality shows now and so you end up
finding that on every network channel in
and a bit number of the cable channels
their network shows if you have an
athlete hosting his/her own network show
then what's the incentive to make it
more outrageous so that you trying to
capture the viewer in the audience and
so that you get renew and so I'm not
sure that when Otis tinkle had his show
on last year that it was just showing
him sing at his dining room table
session after session anyone would have
turned in he knew it so he ends up on
the beach with the whole range of other
both in engaging in other activity means
so it's just part of what for some what
they do on the field ND is upskirt but
they're part of i mean they're smart
enough to understand as something about
how the marketplace works and so you
actually end up separating those who are
themselves working with in the
marketplace one could say manipulative
certainly making use of it in the
parameters within it versus those who
actually have engaged in something that
we may think of us a transgression and
in a long scheme of things it is one
time where they actually did something
like most humans
they wish been up in a newspaper but
because they're high profile it does
mean those are some different categories
of individuals as I sort of think about
the constellation of professional
athletes in the United States and a
range of things that happen and then as
suppose I've known and if you also
prominent enough that their celebrity
hounds following you because they're
going to make money making sure that
they got your picture in a compromised
situation you have a whole other dynamic
so it's not just the individuals but you
have another set of players who
themselves are paid to what you mess up
and then they get to sell that again in
a different way and so part of me it's a
cut you've asked a very complicated
question because you got a spectrum of
individuals engaged in sometimes things
they know they're doing it because it
also knows like in the old days you do
certain things that are outrageous
enough to make sure people come back and
watch the next time around and it's a
trailer to fall in the reality TV shows
or so to become an example of a whole
market of activity yeah and I'll have to
agree with him I was working with CNN
when we started at that time cnns i--
and they tried to have 24-hour sports
and wii u should always say we gotta
feed the monster so we're just looking
for storage to keep being it eventually
they got rid of it as I network but it
is a constant demand to keep those
stories coming so I don't think we can
put the genie back in the bottle anytime
so I don't think so a star athletes are
our celebrities and and and people are
fascinated by them and people want to
know people are fascinating one you know
about what they do off the field and I
mean I kind of agree with you that I
think that what an athlete does on the
field should be the most important thing
but for many people is not and I think
agree with my colleagues it I don't
think it's going to change anytime soon
because people number one people want
that I mean they want those kind of
stories they want to hear that and and
and to this is huge monster that has to
be fed because it's just so much you
know they're all kind of sports
publications and sports media out there
and there has to be fed
okay why are we have full Oh last
question okay Chris very last good to
let alone the last question we have to
save that kind of conversation for our
kind of mixing area right now I want to
first of all say thank you for everyone
coming out this afternoon this has been
very enjoyable I'm again once again our
panelists I want to thank them for
making the trip to come and and for some
of you was around the corner I know but
but for all of you again we appreciate
your support for marble and for what
we're doing at Emory thank you the
preceding program is copyrighted by
emory university